Alma has developed a new kind of
antibiotic for the antibiotic to be
sufficiently effective it has to kill at
least 90% of bacteria when applied to a
harmful bacteria culture she applied her
antibiotic to a petri dish full of
harmful bacteria waited for it to take
effect and then tried to estimate the
percentage of dead bacteria in it she
took a random sample of 300 bacteria and
found that 94% of them were dead then
she calculated the margin of error and
found that the true percentage of dead
bacteria is most likely to be above 90%
so what's happening over here she's
trying to figure out what percentage of
the of the total population of bacteria
died and maybe this is something about
this bacteria maybe just when you look
at it from you know with the naked eye
you can't tell whether the bacteria died
or not and so she decides to estimate
the true percentage by sampling 300
individual bacterium or a sample add I
always forget the singular case by
sampling 300 bacteria and then in her
sample she found that 94% of them were
dead and then the margin of error tells
us because the margin of error says that
it's unlikely or that it's very likely
that the true percentage is above 90%
that means that given that you sample
300 bacteria it's very unlikely that the
true percentage is below 90% so she
could feel reasonably confident that in
her petri dish more than 90 percent of
the population did indeed die now let's
answer these questions what type of
statistical study did Alma use well she
used a she's trying to estimate a
parameter for a population in this case
the parameter was the percentage of all
of the bacteria that died she couldn't
observe that directly so instead she
took a random sample of the bacteria in
the petri dish and she used she
calculated statistic for them 94% of
them were dead and that's her estimate
for the population parameter the
percentage of the population that died
so this is when you're using a when
you're using a random sample to generate
a statistic which estimates a parameter
for a population
that's a sample study so she ran a
sample study now the next question is is
the study appropriate for the
statistical questions it's supposed to
answer so what was the question that
she's trying to answer well at least the
way it's written it seems like she's
trying to answer whether or not her
antibiotic works whether it's an
effective antibiotic whether it's
capable of killing bacteria and you
might be tempted to say okay well look
it looks like it killed it killed more
than 90% of the bacteria it very likely
killed more than 90 percent of the
bacteria given given the the sample size
and the margin error and all that but
even if it is indeed the case that 95%
of all of the bacteria died it doesn't
necessarily mean that it was caused by
the antibiotic maybe it was caused by
the plastic in the petri dish maybe
maybe the air in the petri dish was too
cold or went bad or maybe it was handled
in a weird way or maybe that bacteria
was just a bad a bad a bad culture and
it somehow it just spontaneously died on
its own it's very she can't say with
confidence that it was definitely it was
definitely the antibiotic in order for
her to make that statement she would
have to run a proper experiment she
would have to have a control and a
treatment group where everything is
equal except for the treatment group has
the treatment so if she had two petri
dishes that were helped that were that
were kept in the same conditions with
the same lighting the same air the same
same material that the bacteria is
growing on everything the same except
for the treatment group has the
antibiotic applied to it and then she
saw that in the treatment group that
most of the bacteria died while in the
control group most of the bacteria
didn't die then she could say okay it
looks like the antibiotic caused the
bacteria to dot to die that there was
actual causality here so she would have
had to run an experiment the more the
most appropriate statistical study or
the most appropriate study would have
been a proper controlled experiment
where you have a control group where
they don't have the antibiotic and a
treatment group where they do have the
antibiotic so let's see one of the
choices here where they say is the study
appropriate so yes because she's in a
purpose study no I don't like that
answer
oh because she can't know for certain
that the true percentage of dead
bacterias above 90% well I'm not going
to click on that because even if she
knew for certain that the true
percentage of that dead bacteria were
95% she can't feel confident that it was
due to the antibiotic once again it
could be caused by the air conditioner
could have been caused by the petri dish
it could have been caused by the
lighting in the room so no because the
study didn't have a treatment at a
control group yeah I would go with that
one right over there yes because she
found the antibiotic kills more than 90%
of the harmful bacteria once again even
if she no for knew for sure that more
than 90% of the population had been
killed she doesn't know that it was
caused by the antibiotic it could have
been caused by a whole bunch of things
if she had a control group that had the
exact same conditions and the antibiotic
did and the bacteria didn't die then she
could feel better that it was that the
bacteria death was due to the antibiotic